I think we ran into Ryan probably get
close to ten years ago and we always had
a great time when you came on you're
very open honest you certainly been down
a few roads and coming back
Ryan is program ambassador for a
recovery community called transcend also
a chairman of the focused in10sity
foundation raises scholarship money for
individuals who attend rehab who can't
afford it it's great to see you you look
great you brought your girlfriend looks
like you got life and order here right
yeah today I do yeah yeah um if if you
were gonna recap the last four years for
somebody who had no idea about Riley
how would you recap four years well um
interesting I have a lot of life
experience even more added on to all
this I think that four years ago I got
sick and when I got sick I got offered
pain medication from the doctor and I
never told them that I had a previous
problem I just had to do radiation for a
brain tumor and I just assumed that you
know what everybody else gets to do this
when they're feeling this and I but I
can't I can never take one and I they
gave me those pills December 1st 2012
and by March 30th mm or December 1st
2011 by March 30th 2012 I was in a jail
cell so it took four months for
everything to go away but how when you
took one then you had to have another me
you had to maintain the high no I just
it just became psychological and then
also I was trying to hide it from
everybody and I was out there telling
everybody you know you can just ask for
help you can just ask for help but I was
pretty much just just you know do what I
say not what I do type of thing and that
was just shameful and guilt-ridden I
felt like a hypocrite well you were
doing a book tour exactly and I don't
know if I I hated Schilling for
something that that bothered me I wish I
could have just told my story
and not been like yeah now buy my book I
don't like that part of it and it's
difficult to do is a fine edged sword
but I'm
to make sure that it's always going to
be about somebody other than me now
helping somebody else being of service
not directly affecting me or having to
tell people how well I'm doing because
that's not what I want I don't I could
care less if people still think I'm in
jail or I'm on Skid Row or anything like
that that's that's not the important
part the important part is that I'm I'm
here and I'm saying hey we have a
solution and I can try to help with you
with that how bad did it get well I've
got bad enough that I was willing to
walk into people's homes and take their
pills
that's a morality point of that is I
can't believe that I've never really
been affected by law enforcement ever in
my life and yet I was willing to do that
and I think the best thing that ever
happened to me was being put in jail I
was resentful of it for quite a while
but there comes a point when you accept
that you know what the best thing that
happened was that and that's hard to say
but it's true
what was jail like it was like adult day
care you know they put a 15 inch
flatscreen into your bed with 45
channels and as a babysitter and could
you watch this show I could I've always
enjoyed your show well you were in touch
with Paulie yes sir
the day you got arrested yes sir Iowa
gifts you mailed him you were thinking
about a documentary on your life yeah I
was out of my mind
I don't want a documentary in my life I
don't want to do that but of course I
felt like I had to keep up the charade
of what my life had become now now was
this guy who got it right and now he's
going to tell everybody about it it was
just like I said hypocritical and it's
tough it's fraudulent and I don't
necessarily know what I was doing at
that moment I had publicist I mean it
was that's I don't want to be that guy
anymore I want to be able to enjoy a
weekend in San Francisco maybe do a
little stuff to bring awareness but not
make it all about me and I've really got
an opportunity to see old friends such
as yourselves and a lot of peers that
have just kind of welcomed me back in
open arms and will you'd be surprised
how many people like addicts are great
at fooling people or they think they are
we are yes and and that's
like we were concerned but you were
telling me all the right thing when we
went to lunch that day I we we thought
maybe there was something there but I
didn't know - ed what magnitude but it
felt like you were telling me what I
wanted to hear that day is that true
well I was with you guys in November so
about yeah I was about that bout to go
down that road about three weeks from
there you know I can tell you when it
was when I sat with you guys was in at
the Super Bowl in Indianapolis
we went should have been the grit should
have been the greatest night Polly asked
me to come along - Adam Sandler's
showing a Big Daddy or uh that who's
your daddy that's that's that's my boy
right that's my boy yeah yeah or who's
your dad who's your daddy yeah it's
about it that's my next one with Sandler
who's and uh I got to sit next to him
and he got to look at me and see when I
laughed and I got to interact with the
guy but I was so my mind was so wrapped
up with I I can't wait to get back to
the hotel to take my pills I mean that's
where I was I was in this great
environment Troy Aikman was there you
know yeah there alone Jason Garrett um
Chiara was there I don't know if she was
there yeah she was believe me you see
again I was messed up uh but when you
took that pill what did you feel well I
felt like I deserved it which is oh well
silly because I was going through some
kind of hardship you know life this life
isn't fair it's just how you deal with
it that matters
and I simply didn't know how to deal
with life um
well enough still but did you feel sorry
for yourself because of what happened
with your football career that here you
go number two in the draft Peyton is one
of the greatest of all time and you're
unemployed now did that ever did it did
it start to eat away at your confidence
level your ego self-esteem
I don't know of course I don't think it
I don't think it could I felt like a
failure but what other people think of
me is none of my business as an
affirmation I have to live by every
morning and I try to and it's taken
forever for me to get through that part
of it but the acceptance of that has
helped you know transcend me to this new
plane and like I told you now I'm okay
today you know who knows what's going to
happen tomorrow we'll wake up and do
that that tomorrow with the same process
I know I'm in a very stable environment
in Los Angeles where there is just an
unbelievable recovery community play a
lot of golf get out in nature it's like
a five-hour meditation for me and a good
you so I really really if also it's
almost been four years so that
chemicalize out of my body I never been
that clean for the last you know ten
years of my life have you been close to
it I worked in a sober-living house when
I got out and I was in charge of
medication and I had to distribute them
to claw their clients and that was the
biggest test and it was like it was like
a bartender being an alcoholic right it
was a pretty pretty cool event not only
did I have some accountability but I had
people I could go to when I like when I
looked at him and I said hey you know I
got through this and the people the
support team is a huge part of it we're
talking to Ryan Leaf a former number two
pick in the draft was at 1998 1998 1998
I know that everybody's going to be an
arm-chair therapist with Johnny Manziel
what do you see and being fair to him
because you wouldn't want somebody to do
that to you but if you look at Manziel
warning signs there what would concern
you III said this yesterday feels like
I'm holding up a mirror when I hear some
stories come out I just go oh my god I
did that that's how I behaved I'd like
to say that my substance abuse was the
reason why I played poorly but I didn't
start using drugs until after I retired
so I can't look I can't blame it on that
I just didn't play well um so it's it's
a different a different dynamic that I
don't know about trying to be an NFL
quarterback and then maybe having some
of these substance abuse issues he says
he's fine um he's been to treatment I
don't know what for I think that was a
woman this happened last year I thought
that was the greatest thing imagine if I
would have done that just to go get
behavioral counseling when I was in my
second year when things were falling off
the rails and I thought wow that's a
great thing and sometimes things just
start to spiral and maybe a year you got
to be out of football for a year you got
to get your stuff right because though
this is a great game and it's an
institution in this country it's
fleeting it's gone in a second
everybody's not like Peyton Manning who
can play 18 seasons well the dangerous
part is you think your talent or your
personality or ego can
you through this like I can handle that
you you've handled everything else
adversity you know Manziel handled the
SEC right well of course I can handle
this and that's when you start to give
that false sense of belief that's
exactly how I was to when things started
to go bad I started fighting with the
media and then my teammates I was like
you know I'm the big strong football
player there's no vulnerability in me I
can figure this out leave me alone and
you just can't win that fight you know
you're you're playing the best defenses
every weekend and then fighting the
media all week long it's just exhausting
your central nervous system is on tilt
for about every day for 20 hours would
you want to do a documentary now I think
could help people get into substance
abuse treatment and get into mental
health treatment I know Brandon Marshall
is coming on next he's a big advocate
for that and um you know I got to spend
a lot of time watching you would help I
think it would help young people I agree
I think it'd be cathartic for you as
well I think you'd realize I'm worried
about my family because they live in a
small town and every time I do anything
regardless of the impact it's on the
front page of the newspaper back home
it's a small town and my father is just
is a man of such integrity in his work
and what he's done in this in this
society as well as my in that community
as well as my mother now my little
brother's back there working and stuff
so I don't they just love that I have a
peaceful on chaotic life and that may do
something but it might be nice that if
they get a positive headline there
instead of a negative one true um I
don't necessarily know if there ever
will be positive and I think there can
be but you get you you have you have a
good story it is that's the point and
that's what are alive you're here so
it's a good stone that's the question
people ask me why you continue to do
this you know you've said this before I
said well what am I supposed to do I
supposed to just quit and I am I
supposed to just give it up cuz I was at
a point where I was just gonna give it
up you know I just left my brother I'd
slit my wrists I was in the this was
after I talked to Paulie I was in my
truck pulling into a garage to just park
and kill yourself and that's the mindset
you think there's no way out there's no
support and Johnny maybe same way he
might be just going there's no one
out there to help me but he's probably
got so many people who unconditionally
love him we'll just wrap their arms
around they may love the idea of Johnny
Manziel but they may not know that they
may not know the person the ones that
unconditionally love him they do and
those are the ones that want to wrap
their arms around him and he's just he's
pushed everybody away probably like I
can deal to something else cuz I did it
that's why I say there's a mirror when I
look at it what stopped you from going
in their garage my parents were home
they were there supposed to be a
grandparents house taking care of them
because of the news story that broke and
I just saw it I pulled a u-turn and
instead went out and found another house
and got arrested again found more pills
I said I can't deal with this unless I'm
high I can't kill myself because I'm a
coward so I need to be high and I want
found more pills and then luckily the
you know when I asked God for help you
know this time he sent the sheriff's
that's the only difference because if
they don't come you know if they don't
come my little brother was there to take
care of me but I needed that I needed to
be intervened with so I'm grateful for
that for sure
stay in touch all right I will and if
you get dark you know we'll do something
stupid to cheer you up all right I know
you will I appreciate we do it every
single day
he's Ryan Leaf the program ambassador
for recovery community it's called
transcend also the chairman of the
focused intensity foundation which
raises scholarship money for individuals
to attend rehab who can't afford it good
to see you man thank you can you see can
you give us 60 yards I probably can't
get you six yards but if you try
actually I probably could throw it a
little ways right youth probably then
you can spin it a little bit it's still
Canyon I will go outside and see what
you got out here maybe you can knock
down McLovin oh I don't want to do that
yes we want that you don't askew how a
helmet this time do you what no he had a
helmet last time I'll we can put a
helmet on